he's outspoken critical and
thought-provoking he gets involved
Naveed Kimani the islam scholar and
novelist is committed to bringing
cultures and religions together I was
always a political person I think my
novels are just as political as
everything else I do and that goes for
my scientific books as well 2014 a big
moment for Kimani and for Germany a
child of immigrants the German Iranian
is chosen to hold the laudatory speech
for the 65th anniversary of the German
constitution on behalf of my devout
parents and the now 26 members of my
immigrant family I'd like to at least
symbolically bow and say thank you
Germany he sees himself as a mediator
between Islam and Christianity and
between the mystical and harsh reality
he's travelled the world as a journalist
reporting from war zones and now in the
refugee crisis he's again taking a stand
for an open Germany against a fortress
mentality for karmani the refugees
represent reality breaking into our
consciousness but the author has another
side he also writes about first love
beauty Kafka and Neil Young the
multi-faceted Naveed Kimani a fitting
recipient of this year's Peace Prize of
the German book trade